mettiamo n'è ancora
basterà tutto questo caso per colorarli
capelli
adesso vi mettiamo questa parte della
spazzola
all'interno abbiamo qui il palloncino e
nella nostra penna con la graffetta
appuntita pronta a farlo esplodere sulla
testa di anita allora devi aprire subito
è grazie benvenuti solita storici siete
pronti sto organizzando già un
bellissimo scherzetto per vitale berlino
fai la guardia e controlla che è vitale
non arrivi ok
avvisami se si sta vicino vi spiego
subito che scherzetto andrò a fare a
vitale prima di iniziare lasciate un bel
mi piace su questo video lo scorso video
degli scherzi vi è piaciuto tanti di voi
questo video raggiunge il 20 mila mi
piace andremo a fare una quarta parte in
cui proviamo tantissimi scherzetti
guerra degli scherzi quindi lasciate un
bel mi piace se non mi seguite ancora su
instagram andati a seguirmi il nome di
the stories se volete seguitemi anche su
the doc
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn
iniziamo subito con il primo scare
questo primo scherzetto è perfetto per
evitare perché vitale mi ruba sempre il
cibo infatti io ogni tanto lo nascondo
guardate guardate chi azzecca un pacco
di patatine e ho in mente uno scherzetto
fantastico che ho visto da 123 gol che
mi avete scritto no o se dice in inglese
world trade day one frigo
eccolo qua
[Musica]
questo era lo scherzetto speriamo di
riuscirci bene allora innanzitutto vado
a svuotare il pacco di patatine a
sperando che vitale non sente l'odore
non arrivi subito è appena arrivato
merlino per controllare e merlino vuoi
fare anche chiude gli scherzi a vitale a
un romanzo tu ti devi alleare con me
questa guerra degli scherzi non con
vitali che a maggio ok grazie grazie per
questi bacini
grazie esigibili merlino e la mascotte
della story stabili prima questa cosa a
spuntare no merlino non sono per te e
ora andiamo a mettere il gavettone qua
dentro
spero di riuscirci mai né berlino non è
per te no no no no stanno per evitare
cioè non sono neanche totale non puoi
mangiarle fu berlino
dai non ci rimane male tu devi mangiare
il cibo perché sa di non puoi mangiare
le patatine
ok ragazzi ecco qua riempito il
palloncino d'acqua che cosa è questo
merlino darà si mangia marlino prova
sempre a mangiare tutto un po come
perché mi stai dando la zappa nei punti
ma l'assenza comunque lo riempito
abbastanza vediamo se ci sta dentro al
pacco di brink
ecco è entrato ok ora devo stare super
attenta e richiuderlo prima con questa
parte poi con la parte di plastica così
non se ne accorse ce l'ha fatta
l'unico problema è che devo stare
attenta a non far vedere questa parte
del palloncino a vitale così lui aprirai
pringles eli spruzzerà tutta la bomba
d'acqua addosso almeno spero che
funzioni
devo stare attenta a coprire qua coprirò
così con la ma ora non ci resta che
chiamare vitale finale ieri ho qualcosa
da mangiare
no
hai fame tanto ai moltissimo parla
allora devi aprire subito è pronto
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]
non ci credo giocato benissimo e grandi
attori saranno buttati nei adesso mi
dispiace bisogno bellissimo perché da
qua è uscita la fontanella ecceduto in
testa si arrabbia tema libero è troppo
divertente va bene o male invece berlino
fa così ogni volta che si bagna il muso
berlino fa così non lo so è un po strano
esiste anche i vostri cani sono così
strani che ogni volta che si bagnano in
uso fanno così per asciugarsi brioschi
ferirsi ma anche se vitale ora è
arrabbiato non perché si è bagnato ma
perché non gliela doveva dare e comunque
volevo dirti che chi la fa l'aspetti
mi sono dimenticato di dirvi alla fine
dei bio dovrete votare il vostro scherzo
preferito quindi guardate il video fino
alla fine visto che anita mi ha bagnato
con questo scherzo col palloncino ha
deciso di ricambiare il favore come un
palloncino riviera da acqua questo
scherza l'ho visto dal canale one two
trillo
[Musica]
vediamo subito il necessario abbiamo
bisogno di un palloncino ora penna una
matita e una graffetta alle solite
perfette con lei per carta per documenti
insomma è ovviamente un pochettino di
scotch il mostro subito come fare
dobbiamo prendere la graffetta queste
graffette qui e dobbiamo tirare all'insù
il lato questo qui non è appuntito però
diciamo il lato dove finisce la
graffetta e lo andiamo a tenere proprio
qui sulla tempo e ci aiutiamo con un po
di scotch
questo infatti servirà a bucare il
palloncino che ripieno d'acqua le farò
unghia vettore sulla testa allo punterò
sulla porta ovviamente lo fissiamo alla
penna ed abbiamo qui la nostra penna
graffetta tenta impronta a far esplodere
in testa il palloncino adatta alla vita
adesso vado a riempire il palloncino
d'acqua e lo vado a mettere sopra la
porta e vi faccio vedere
guardate con reddito di alettone che
arriverà intestata vita e adesso con
l'aiuto della sedia non ho però proprio
passò la mente con dello scotch lo
andiamo a fissare a bassora attaccato
con lo scorso proprio lì sulla porta e
adesso attaccherò con lo scotch anche la
penna proprio all'altezza del palloncino
fatto abbiamo qui palloncino è la nostra
penna con la graffetta appuntita pronta
a farlo esplodere sulla testa di anita
posizionato tutto là sopra sia a
palloncino che la perna con graffetta
adesso non ci resta altro che chiamare
anita vieni
hai sentito questo rumore era fuori
non lo so ho visto qualcuno forse sono i
ladri vieni dentro e chiudi la porta si
viene divenire viene a nascondersi qui
chiudi la porta che la portavoce
[Musica]
come avevo detto prima che tutti i piedi
adesso pride a mia vendetta non venivano
le patatine che avevo detto qua perché
sono la metà le hai mai già detto di
akashi fatto di nascosto
e prossimo scherzo ho in mente uno
scherzo molto cattivo per vitale così
impara a farmi gavettoni nave che glie
l'ho fatto anch'io questo scherzo è
molto divertente
gliela faccio vedere subito
[Musica]
ok per questo scherzo ci basta il
cestino un foglio di carta già puntato
pc scott e farina
tra l'altro chip italy sta usando dei
polimeri e quindi la marina si vedrà
ancora di più non vedo l'ora di vedere
la sua reazione sarà super divertente
ok ragazzi
ecco pronto il cestino volta che
schiaccerà il pedale si aprirà ora devo
solo mettere la farina qua sopra
ok è tutto pronto o no devo andare
lavarmi le mani altrimenti se ne
accorgerà poi mi devo inventare una
scusa per farli aprire il cestino
potrei dire che è accaduto qualcosa
dentro che c'è un topo dentro tipo di
dominio
i suoi cani qualcosa qua dentro gestivo
come peggio per medie e subito qua c'è
qualcosa che mi guardo da dentro cestino
c'è qualcosa che si muove dentro
giustino toc toc chi è che un dopo tipo
un oggetto chiamato berlino così si
mangia potrebbe essere che cos'è quella
c'è la farina qua sopra perché sta
pensando di farti dei biscotti e
misfatti mai solo con la farina devi
prendere anche gli altri ingredienti per
farle ma ho iniziato a prendere questo
l'ingrediente e poi prenderò anche gli
altri ma cosa me ne frega adesso se ti
sto facendo i biscotti una torta o
qualcos'altro riportate che aprì cestino
per controllare quello che ci mettete
nei tempi dai aprile controlla contro un
pochettino non sento muoversi niente dai
membri controlla
[Musica]
scherzo finito perché per fortuna
versati lato infatti altrimenti tutto è
cambiato radicalmente riuscito sui
pantaloni neri ha nascosto che mi ha
fatto prima anni dopo la farina devo
dire che mi è piaciuto tanto anche se mi
ha sporcato i pantaloni è stato davvero
divertente
questa volta però farò lo scherzo io ad
anita che sarà uno scherzo che avrà a
che fare coi capelli sarà troppo
divertente proprio come in questo video
qui guardate
[Musica]
le andrò a rubare la spazzola farò una
piccola modifica questa spazio enit che
c'è una spazzola per favore che mi devo
pettinare ti devi pettinari segreti ma
nei capelli con i capelli corti e che
c'entra avere capelli corti non lupo di
mare è strano perché tu non ti pettini
mai come lo ripetiamo ma di certo che
bigliettino i pettini con le dita c'è
qualcosa di strano
l'uomo non c'è proprio niente di strano
è una mary ma riporta mela subito che i
sing the body pettinarmi grazie a un
gioco da ragazzi spazio allora per prima
cosa dobbiamo togliere questa parte qui
e poi cercare di farlo uscire dai body
un facilissimo proprio così è stato
gioco da ragazzi e poi prendiamo il
nostro amico la grecia e lo mettiamo
all'interno
[Musica]
mettevano è ancora fatta basterà tutto
questo caso per colorarli capelli
adesso lo rimettiamo questa parte della
spazzola all'interno chi quasi fatto
atta profumatissima state non si vede
proprio niente a parte sotto che un po
fredda perché ovviamente il cash 8 stavo
in frigo e quindi un pochettino fredda
altrimenti non si vede proprio nulla
perfetta proprio come faccio adesso però
convinceranno i tappeti narsi si stava
truccando ma si era già pettinata
preparato l'idea la vado a spettinare
così lei è costretto a venire qui a
prendere la spazzola ritirarsi sono
geniali quarta bene cosa mi salta per la
testa di eto'o non risulta niente per la
destra bene così vero eccola è proprio
qui la spazzola tieni
sento un odore strano di patatine fritte
sì perché la mia testa di patatine
fritte giustamente hai mangiato troppo
fragile la verità sì certo un gioco
fianco non sovrasta legittimati e guerri
così come riassume il fatto che gli è
caduto tutto chiesa più testa così
impari farris che ti conviene
questa tantissimo berlino è tutta colpa
di evitare un nuovo bar mi ha messo in
casa bianca pensa tu non puoi mangiare
capito solo ai pure la maggiore dire che
non mi lascia più berlino vuole
mangiarmi i capelli e la spazzola bene
questi erano gli scherzi alla fine il
più grande anima e quello che mi hai
fatto tu beh basta per impresa più cosa
terribile è di 20 cv con 20 qual è stato
il vostro scherzo preferito per me il
mio preferito è stato quello delle free
corse palloncino mi è caduta in pazza a
me invece quello della farina mi è
piaciuto tantissimo anche sono subito
però ci sono questo e quello un po più
cattivello accanto ad anna grazia tempo
il bcs se volete vedere un quarto
episodio della
tranne gli scherzi e ora vi lascio ba4
casilino su cui di care per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
[Musica]